for 17 years
where's your family from which Village
yeah
and my grandfather was a dentist
because you don't deserve anything what
you think are making sure
who cares
you you keep saying yeah love you're a
journalist you have one-sided motion
I've had enough of your journalism you
want to say show people what you're
doing in Palestine show what you're
doing to the Christian first before you
do it to the Muslims
every Christian in any country who
support your terrorism it's a terrorists
are you willing to dialogue
shut up and listen
my grandmother was giving birth and she
had to stay while my grandfather had to
take their children out so don't you